hey can i bring up a sub
the subject of breaking your ankle real
quick sure like i just want you to know
that ken block
tried to get me to like stand on a
ladder
and let him slide through and have me
like
like jump off and and i got there and
i'm like i [ __ ] like i'm not [ __ ]
breaking an ankle over this [ __ ]
yeah like i [ __ ] he was so bummed had
the whole thing
set up and i wouldn't do it yeah and
then fast forward
where you [ __ ] grab a board and are
[ __ ] gonna boneless through a [ __ ]
car
like and it's still it still blows my
mind that you did so many clean
clean ones and then got the wonky fall
one that got it but i
i i it reminds me of why i'm glad i also
never did it
for sure dude for people who maybe don't
know what rob is talking about
my idea was to uh stand on a
wooden out house i was thinking [ __ ]
full eight feet
tall and i think it initially it was
just i was gonna be
on the outhouse and uh and our boy danny
wade
drove a car crashing through it with me
on the roof and it would just drop me to
the ground
i did it with just sitting on it at one
point [ __ ] fell down i was like dude
[ __ ] that i got this dude i'm gonna
[ __ ] jump a skateboard off the boat
while the car crashes through the
port-a-potty did it a bunch of times we
went through like three or four
porta-potties
and then uh we were down to the last one
and i was like [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ]
stick this landing
and i wasn't even on the board but i
thought i was and i just fought to
[ __ ] stick the landing and all i did
was just
shatter my ankle oh man
it's still hard for me to even just
just anytime you see that foot just
l-shaped yes it's like it's the worst
thing to see
you know i think that like generally
people
have a pretty easy time looking at their
own injuries
but more difficult time looking at like
really gruesome injuries
of others or i might have that wrong but
i'm saying that i'm
skateboard injuries are tougher for me
because it's like
way more in like like where things could
happen to me like something that
that's in my line of fire that's more
spooky to me to look at
than something that's just kind of even
though full scarred level
bone breaks we don't put them on
ridiculousness right like
like even if you do shatter something
you can't tell right like because it's
like
any time you see that snap it's just
it's just a little
little bit too it loses its fun right
right
yeah dude